>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Annette McLean: Good evening,
welcome to our Founders Day Weekend.
I'm Anne McLean from the
Library's Concert Office
and we are very excited
to be celebrating 90 years
of legendary concerts here at the
Library of Congress this season.
Nine decades after the
Library opened in October 1925,
concerts from the Library
of Congress is alive,
vibrant and colorful.
And it's exciting and exhilarating
to be celebrating our history
and looking forward to the future
with a splendid lineup
of more than 95 events.
This weekend we're honoring the
150th anniversary of the founder
of our concerts, Elizabeth Sprague
Coolidge, an extraordinary woman,
extraordinary philanthropist,
and extraordinary role model.
Today, October 30th,
is her birthday,
day that we mark each season
with a special project.
And I'm happy to say that two of
her great granddaughters are here
with us, Jose and Peg
[inaudible], so welcome to them.
[ Applause ]
Mrs. Coolidge, as many of you
know already, was a brilliant
and formidable woman,
pianist, composer, [inaudible]
and a passionate advocate
for chamber music.
She endowed our superb concert hall
and supervised it's construction.
She established our concert
series here through a concept
that was visionary and
radical for its time,
a public/private partnership, a
path breaking innovation signed
into law by Calvin Coolidge.
And if you have our brochure
you can see a reprint image
of that first bill.
This was a first.
Her gesture was a first.
Her vision and her leadership
which has made possible
nearly 3000 concerts and more
than 100 significant
Coolidge Foundation commission
for the Library was the spark for
our panel tonight, A Leading Role:
A Conversation on Women
in the Music World.
And I wanted to say, too, that
you can see in a handsome exhibit
about Mrs. Coolidge
and her life and career
over in the James Madison
Building across the street.
It's beautifully put together and
curated by our two colleagues,
Robin Rousch [assumed
spelling] and Katelyn Miller.
This weekend we have concerts that
reflect Mrs. Coolidge's interests
in music, both very new,
tomorrow's concert --
or tonight's concert
by a modern master
and vocal magician, Meredith Monk.
And also music that was very old.
Tomorrow we have Pomerium,
a vocal ensemble performing
music of renaissance masters.
So I'd like to introduce our
distinguished panel tonight,
and I'm very grateful
to these speakers.
We are honored to have as our
featured speaker, Jane Chu,
Chairman of the National
Endowment of the Arts.
It's [inaudible] to have you here.
[ Applause ]
Chairman Chu is the 11th
chairman of the NEA appointed
by President Obama in 2014.
In addition to awarding
nearly $220 million
in grants during her tenure just to
date, she's also launched a number
of new programs, and including
one called Creative Connections,
we'll hear about --
Creativity Connects, pardon me,
which we'll hear about later.
She is a pianist and a
former concert presenter,
and this was of great interest
to us when she was appointed.
From 2006 to 2014 she was president
and CEO of the Kauffman Center
for the Performing Arts
in Kansas City, Missouri,
overseeing a $413 million
campaign to build that center.
She holds a doctorate
in Philanthropic Studies
and a background in fundraising
and development is an
important part of her portfolio.
We are very, very pleased to be
able to work closely with the NEA
and we will talk a little bit
more about the intersection
between public and private funding
and developing those initiates.
Cellist and educator, Astrid
Schween, is admired internationally
as both a solo and chamber
artist, long-time member
of the Lark Quartet, with whom she
has performed here at the Library.
She's now performing with the Boston
Trio and she's a professor of Cello
at the University of Massachusetts.
In 2016 she will join the Julliard
String Quartet, whom I know many
of you are fans of, replacing
cellist Joel Krosnick,
and will join the faculty
at the Juilliard School.
Margaret Lioi --
[ Applause ]
Margaret Lioi is CEO of Chamber
Music America, founded 28 years ago
to develop, support and
strengthen the chamber music field,
and I'm glad to say that the
Library has been a member
since the very early days of the
founding of the organization.
She too has a background
very impressive
in performance and business skills.
She has an MBA in Arts
Administration,
and has held the post of
Director or Development
for the Spoleto Festival USA,
and the Executive Director
of the Eleanor Naylor
Dana Charitable Trust.
And I'd like to say that CMA is
a very important commissioner
of new music, offering a number
of commissions, and we will talk
about commissioning a little later.
We would like to get started with
hearing from these experts on many,
many areas of the world of music
and business as they intersect.
And we would like to start
off with Astrid Schween.
>> Astrid Schween: Okay.
Good evening.
Hi, this is [inaudible].
Okay. So I put together a little
narrative of what my life is
like as a teacher, as a
performer, as a mentor.
I found this a wonderful
exercise and a great way to kind
of explore the impact I am and
perhaps am not having on people
around me, so I've
prepared a little something.
My perspective on women in the
music world has been shaped
by my activities as a
performer, teacher and mentor.
In these roles I've spent much
of my time focusing on aspects
that are largely technical,
analytical,
diagnostic and practical.
As a teacher one of my
primary responsibilities is
to address the needs
of each student,
and help balance their strengths and
weaknesses as developing cellists.
Each student is different,
and the work tends to focus
on individual issues
that are independent
of race, gender or even age.
My perspective has
also been influenced
by a very diverse family life that
included a rich network of friends
and family members from multiple
cultures and backgrounds.
My parents even chose my schools
to reflect a similarly
mixed population.
There was also never
any doubt at home
that I would pursue a
professional career.
And it's nice to see a clip
like that from [inaudible],
I can understand that motivation.
I later discovered that these
values, which I took for granted,
were not necessarily consistent
with some of the conventions
of the times, such as those
I found during summer visits
to my father's family
in post war Germany,
or even in some suburban communities
closer to home, or the attitudes
of some teachers that boys,
as future breadwinners,
would be more focused
attention than girls.
My most direct mentorship
experience as a young cellist was
with the great cellist,
Jacqueline du Pre.
Through a series of lucky events
I was able to work with her
and made numerous trips to London
over the course of seven years,
while still a student at Juilliard.
My lessons with Jacqueline
were unique.
As someone who had lost the ability
to play because of her illness,
she learned to communicate
the essentials by singing
and making gestures with her arms.
We listened to recordings
and she would explain what she
had been thinking interpretively
and while on stage.
These musically in-depth sessions
always included at least one meal,
several cups of tea,
and lots of stories
about her life as a touring artist.
Normally you spend one hour
with your teacher each week,
or a little more with studio class
time, but in this case I was invited
into the thought process
and creative process
in a way that was completely new.
Jacqueline took the time to share
with me and explain from the point
of view of a performer
the nuts and bolts
of assembling an interpretation
and rending it practically
through the instrument.
To me this was the
essence of mentorship.
Women in the music world, with
quotes, took on new meaning
when I became of an all
women string quartet.
I started traveling
extensively with the Lark Quartet
for concerts, tours
and competitions.
This very valuable professional
experience included both mentoring
students of my own during quartet
residencies at various institutions
around the country, as well
as being mentored by some
of the great chamber music
artists of the generation,
who worked with us as we
prepared for competitions.
These included members of the
Budapest, Amadeus, Bardeen,
[inaudible] Juilliard
and LaSalle quartets.
With Jackie my lessons were all
about how do you make
this particular sound,
how do you sustain this line,
how do you play with more power,
how do you conserve your energy, how
does one imitate the human voice.
With these quartet masters it
tended to be more about illustrating
to the audience the architecture
and form of a complete work.
From these people I learned
a lot about collaboration,
how to assemble a piece
and convey it's substance
to an audience, and how to rehearse.
It was also essential to
my development as a coach
of other chamber musicians.
My time with the Lark Quartet
also brought experience
with commissioning composers and
premiering and recording new works.
The Lark was founded on the
mission to expand the repertoire
through funded commissions.
During these years we worked a
great deal with organizations
like Chamber Music America, thank
you, applying for both residency
and commissioning grants.
We worked with other organizations
such as the Minnesota's
Composers Forum,
the National Orchestral
Association, which was funded
by the Judson Foundation,
and the Mars
and Alma Shapiro Fund,
to name a few.
Interestingly, all of these
organizations featured women
in leadership roles.
And it was with each of them
that we had direct communication
when making our applications
for funds.
Over the years the Quartet
commissioned numerous works
from some of the most
celebrated composers.
These pieces were significant
for our career building.
Being the first ensemble to record
them helped establish the Quartet
in the mainstream of the American
chamber music scene for many years.
Some of the commissions
included works
for string quartet plus a guest
artist, which opened the way
for broader collaborations.
These patrons, in ways not unlike
Elizabeth Sprague Coolidge expanded
the standard repertoire and
helped advance the careers
of some now very well
known female composers.
When Lark traveled internationally
we were generally well received.
Occasionally we would be found
"charming and adorable" [laughter]
or perhaps related to as
though we were a group
of girls enjoying some kind
of hobby or field trip,
with frequently the assumption
that making a family
would inevitably take our
interests elsewhere.
Over the course of the 20 plus
years since I joined the group,
and since my time with
Jackie du Pre,
these kinds of assumptions have
diminished somewhat, and I now work
with a group of students
that is mostly female.
More recently in my work at cello
professor at UMass, Mount Holyoake
and elsewhere, I've observed some
of the different ways in leadership
and mentoring can take shape.
The students in the music
department at UMass are by
and large pre-professional
musicians,
focusing on cello performance
and music [inaudible].
When working with these
students I draw heavily
on my most profound mentorships
experiences as a student,
such as my work with Jackie du Pre
or Eugene Moye, cellist in New York,
or my many others teachers
and mentors.
In fact, it's not uncommon in
the middle of a lesson to feel
as though I'm channeling
the advice of one or another
of my many teachers, when I'm
helping a student with a problem.
The how to is really in
the foreground at UMass,
and the pressure is on for
immediate practical results
that will prepare students
for professional work.
In addition to providing
musical demonstrations,
I have to provide them with a
template for entering working life
as a string player, whether
that involves further study
or starting orchestral auditions,
or enrolling in competitions
that not only can they
play all the notes,
but they have internalized
the [inaudible]
of the professional
musician and are prepared
to collaborate successfully.
This includes the understanding
that those
who take a more entrepreneurial
role are more likely to succeed.
In contrast, the liberal arts agenda
at Mount Holyoake College
represents --
or presents me with cello students
who are frequently
majoring in other fields.
My role there is to give them a
deeper understanding and sense
of confidence navigating
a piece of music.
As a women's college with a
tradition of preparing women
for leadership, the school
values classroom experience
that contributes to the basic
goals of thinking independently
and analytically, speaking and
writing effectively, and connecting
with the broader community.
While preparing a piece of music one
draws upon many of the analytical
and communication skills
required for effective leadership.
In our lessons and
coaching sessions,
there are surprising numbers
of parallels that can be drawn
between musical performance
and clear thinking
and communication in general.
In true Mount Holyoake style
orchestra members rotate leadership
positions, as board
members, directors of marking
and fundraising committees and more.
They are thoroughly self-sustaining.
Both of these institutions
are actively engaged
to advance women in
leadership roles.
For example, as recently as last
year UMass developed a program known
as Priming Women for Public
Leadership, and Mount Holyoake
as a vast array of programs,
including Women Leading
in Public Service Summit 2015.
As I prepare to join the Juilliard
faculty and my new colleagues
in the Juilliard Quartet, I am
learning more about the school
and the many ways it has changed
since I was a student there.
To my delight, Juilliard
has made a tremendous effort
to offer a broad array of courses,
to the point of creating whole
departments geared toward career
building, entrepreneurship,
educational outreach,
mentoring and innovation.
Things have changed a
lot since I was kid.
Initiatives such as Julliard's
Music Advancement program,
the Boston Symphony
Orchestra's Project STEP,
and the Sphinx Organization
in Detroit have brought a much more
diverse generation of musicians
into the world of music, and
that world is showing signs
of being more inclusive and more
like the tapestry I grew up with.
So it's very interesting to be here
and hear what my two co panelists
will have to say about the state
of women in music, but is
a very nice exploration.
Thank you for inviting me.
>> Annette McLean: Well,
you know, it's very resonate
to hear your comments,
especially in this room
with the [inaudible]
instruments there that were played
for so many years by
the Budapest Quartet.
And they were, as Robert
[inaudible] used to say,
the most famous quartet known by
name in the world at that time.
And our friend, June Schneider,
is here who was married
to Mischa Schneider, the
cellist of the Budapest Quartet
and June is a longtime -- she
came to a concert first year
in 1946, so she's here tonight.
And for the Juilliard
we presented them --
we have presented them for 67 of the
70 years they have been in business.
So the Library is a
place where stories
and relationships and
families are grown.
And this -- Margaret, this
applies to you very much.
We -- as I say, we feel a part
of a Chamber Music America.
You have been very, very hands-on
at CMA in developing a number
of new program initiatives to
encourage a diversity of expression,
and we'd love to hear about that.
>> Margaret Lioi: Well,
I'll begin by saying
that I never use GPS,
I always use a map.
[Applause] Now, I'm
surprised to hear applause.
I thought people would probably
say, what does that have
to do with women in the arts.
Everything.
And the reason is, I use a map
because when I'm going on a trip I
like to know not just where I'm
starting from and where I'm going,
but I like to know, oh, what
does the interstate cross,
and maybe there are
mountains over here, or a lake
or maybe I'll take a detour,
so I like the bigger picture.
And I realized that I do
the same thing in my work.
I don't just think of chamber
music or even the performing arts,
but I look at the bigger landscape.
I look at what's happening
at economically and socially
and with technology and
the political landscape.
And I think that we all get a
clearer picture of where we are
in the larger world, where
there might be opportunities,
where there might be
gaps that we can fill in.
So thinking of this conversation
in the larger context
I thought I would start
out where I often start out,
which is the Census Bureau.
I love reading Census Bureau
statistics [laughter].
I know it sounds a little boring,
but really you can find out so much
about where you are and
where you might want to go.
So according to the Census
Bureau women's presence
in the labor force has increased
dramatically, from about 30 million
in 1970 to 73 million in 2010.
Now to put that into
context, in 1970 there were
about 80 million workers total,
so of those total workers,
about 38% were women.
And in 2010 there were 154
million workers, so the percentage
of women had risen to about 47%.
But the types of jobs
that most women held
in 1970 were dental assistants,
teachers, secretaries and nurses.
And in fact, I graduated from
high school right around that time
and I was one of three women
out of -- we had a class --
I went to a women's high school,
we had a class of about 200.
I was one of three that was
pursuing a career in the arts,
all the other classmates were going
to nursing school or
becoming teachers.
And that was actually confirmed
at my last high school reunion,
when we found that in fact most
of the class had had careers
in teaching and nursing.
The career guidance available
at that time for women wanting
to pursue a performing
career didn't exist.
I studied piano with the
Eastman School of Music
in the Preparatory Division, and
my teacher wanted me to continue
in the college division of Eastman,
but I wanted to expand
my world view.
Now expand my worldview is a
euphemism for I wanted to get
out of Rochester, New
York [laughter],
even though Eastman is a wonderful
school, but I just felt there had
to be a place where the sun came out
more than in Rochester, New York.
Now I had absolutely no
idea what I was doing.
There were some well known
women pianists at the time,
but I didn't particularly
want to be a performer,
I just knew that I loved
music, I loved the piano,
and I wanted in some way to have
a career in the performing arts.
So the way I could see that
at that time was to continue
with the instrument that
I had been studying.
So we'll fast forward through four
years of college and two years
of graduate school, and after
six years I had much improved
as a musician and had as
few prospects for employment
as I had had six years before.
And, again, there were few
women professors of piano
at New England Conservatory.
They were not young women, and I
really could not identify with them.
My old teacher was a man,
a wonderful man named Jacob
Maxim, excellent teacher.
I loved him.
But he was not a mentor,
he was very reclusive.
As a matter of fact, he himself had
stopped performing because he had
such anxiety before
he got onto the stage.
And so I thought, I'm not sure
that that's really the person
I want for a mentor [laughter].
But we remained close,
he just passed away recently,
he was a wonderful man.
But after I graduated I
became a freelance musician,
primarily for vocalists.
And this actually turned into
a career as an accompanist,
which is now of course
called collaborative piano.
And I often say, if it had
truly been collaborative
when I was doing it I would have
remained in that profession.
[ Laughter ]
I played with some
wonderful musicians, I toured,
I played for opera rehearsals and
dance classes and music theater,
you name it and I played for it.
Freelancers live in fear of
never getting another job,
so you take any job at any
time that comes your way,
and that becomes its own
problem which is another panel,
which we'll schedule
some time [laughter].
So this went on until I turned 30,
and I had this really lightning bolt
realization that I had no savings,
no stability, I was
working seven days a week,
and I had lost a clear direction.
My direction became maintenance.
Did I have enough money for
rent, food, and gas for my car.
It was a very short-term plan,
very short-term existence.
So at that time I met a woman
who was getting an MBA
in Arts Administration.
I had no idea that
such a thing existed.
There was actually a job
called an Arts Administrator.
And it does seem ridiculous to
me now, but at that time I was
so focused on playing that
it never occurred to me
that someone was actually in charge
of the organizations
that were hiring me.
So let's -- we'll fast forward
again for another couple of years.
I did get my MBA and I began to work
for arts organizations
on the business side.
So now that I'm running
a national organization,
I'd like to share a few things
that I have observed in my career.
They're not necessarily related,
but they all sort of fit the idea
that we're talking about tonight.
I've never had a female boss.
Every organization I've worked
for has been led by men.
They're wonderful, smart,
talented, creative and charismatic,
but I think it's interesting that
since I had come up in my career,
so many more organizations
are run by women.
And I'll get to that
in just a moment.
According to the National
Partnership for Women and Families,
on average, women earn 77 cents
for every dollar earned by men.
And I did experience this firsthand
when I moved to New York to work
for the Charitable Trust.
My predecessor had been a gentleman,
and since I was the
trust's chief administrator,
I had payroll responsibilities.
So in reviewing the payroll records
it came to [laughter] my attention
that I was being paid exactly
50% less than he had been paid.
That was quite a shock.
There are still very few
mentorship programs for women
who are interested in pursuing
arts administration career paths.
There are many women who
are members of ensembles
and notably some ensembles are
composed entirely of women.
But there are still relatively
few women in major orchestras.
The paths from performing
to administration are
very serendipitous.
There are few official structures
where performers can know
about the existence of arts jobs
and arts administration programs.
The wage discrepancy issue that I
mentioned earlier has been talked
about for years, but another
aspect of this conversation
that women continue to face
is the work/life balance.
Our cultural understanding
of mothers
and fathers roles really
must be further examined,
and our administrative work places
need to become more family friendly.
Young women who look to
the arts for careers have
so many high profile role models
now that didn't exist years ago.
In addition to my co panelists
who have very high profile
and prominent jobs in the
arts, there's Deborah Borda
who is president and CEO of
the Los Angeles Philharmonic,
and the Fellow New England
Conservatory [inaudible] I'm happy
to say.
There's your own Deborah Rutter who
is president of the Kennedy Center,
and before that of
the Chicago Symphony.
And we just saw Marin Alsop, Music
Director of the Baltimore Symphony.
So these women who are prominent
in the arts, in administration,
and in performing, and they
can become now role models
for the younger generation.
They have become role
models for younger women.
So I have a vision for the field
of arts of administration that I'd
like to share with
you for the year 2025.
We'll reconvene then maybe,
Anne, and we'll have this panel
and see if we've gotten there.
Learning the principles of arts
administration will be required
for anyone studying
the performing arts.
This will be the norm
and not the exception.
For those seeking arts
administration careers,
paid internships will
part of their curriculum.
Salaries in arts administration
positions will not be lower
than their counterparts
in the for profit arena.
And artists and arts administrators
will be welcomed additions
to the boards of civic
organizations and corporations
because of the creativity
and innovative thinking
that they bring to the table.
And there will be parody among men
and women in wages, family care,
and job opportunities
throughout the field.
I think we can do it,
and I look forward
to being a part of that world.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Annette McLean: Wonderful.
And Chairman Chu, you have
the very broadest overview
of all aspects of music
in our nation.
>> Jane Chu: Well, I -- now
I'm in a position where I focus
on all the arts, all the
genders, and appreciate them all.
But I come today with a perspective
of my own love for music,
and my own musical training
and how it has informed
my own leadership style.
I don't think that there's
ever been a better time
to appreciate what the arts can
provide in terms of leadership.
Because we live in this world that
is filled with constant change,
and there's new information
flying toward us
from multiple directions
simultaneously
and everybody has an opinion and
everybody wants the opinion heard.
And so we need creative
leaders who will sort through
and bring together
those [inaudible] pieces
and who will find new
solutions to be able
to bridge those opposing
perspectives.
And for me, and possible for
you, and certainly my panelists,
the arts are a key piece in building
new paths toward this common ground.
So I was born into
multiple cultures,
often with seemingly
opposing perspectives,
and if I had not been involved
in the arts I'm not sure
that I would have been able to
make as much sense of my own life.
My parents met in the United
States, but both came from China,
during a time when their home
country was in a lot of turmoil.
They came to America in the
1940s, or 1948 and 1949,
and they never saw
their families again.
I on the other hand was born in
Oklahoma and I grew up in Arkansas,
11,000 miles away from China,
and equally as far away
from the traditional
Chinese way of life.
So I juggled living in two
opposite cultures simultaneously.
They spoke Mandarin
to each other at home,
but they wanted me to speak English.
They liked to eat bok
choy and noodles,
I liked to eat pizza and corn dogs.
So I've really grown up navigating
through situations where people
around me have different
perspectives,
and many times they're opposite
from each other, and learning how
to appreciate those bok
choy/corn dog settings
without force fitting everybody
to be exactly like each other.
And in the midst of
those settings the arts,
and in particular my music training,
have been the most soothing form
of expression and of
communication for me.
And so they opened the door for me
to develop my own leadership skills.
And I've come to realize
that the type
of really effective leadership
that's needed for tomorrow's leaders
and probably for today boils
down to only one thing,
and that is how we do
something, how we lead is just
as important as what we do.
How we do something is just
And I can say without reservation
that my own musical training
has given me techniques to use
when working with others,
for example,
in working with different styles.
Even if you have a job where
you work mostly in solitude,
there will always be times
when you work alongside others.
And when you work with others
you will encounter people
with different styles,
different ways of doing things,
certainly different perspectives
from yours, and this can happen
with the smallest nuance.
You might make a comment as a
leader, and somebody on your team,
because they have a
completely learning style,
may interpret your comment in
a completely different way.
So working with other
people also requires
that I have an understanding of how
my coworkers assemble information,
how they make decisions,
how they act at work.
I don't perform Beethoven the
same way I perform [inaudible],
and I don't approach a coworker
who is focused upon facts
and logical analysis the same
way I approach another coworker
who is focused on whether
they feel good in a situation.
And so in one of my previous
jobs I had a board member
who had almost the exact
opposite style from me,
and this board member turned out
to be one of my greatest gifts.
Because I had to really prepare
myself when I communicated with him,
and sometimes sending him an e-mail
message took a long time for me
to compose even a paragraph,
because I knew
that he would read
the message from me
from his own perspective
and now mine.
So I couldn't insert any
shorthand words or make any leaps
because he would either
jump to the wrong conclusion
or he would just not get it.
But he was such a good board member
and he had so much information
and experience that would
make the organization better,
as long as I understood how
to communicate with him.
So thank goodness for
my musical training,
because if the board member was,
say, a Hindemith piano sonata
and I was a Scarlatti sonata then I
made sure that I learned how to play
in the style of Hindemith.
And so as a result I became
a far more versatile leader,
with more tools in my
leadership tool belt
as a result of my musical training.
In listening to others, and
paying attention how to listen
to my environment, my
musical training taught me how
to listen with a keen ear.
So to hear the nuances of
a composition, many people,
perhaps most, can tell
the difference
between loud versus quiet.
But my musical training taught
me to differentiate between forte
and [inaudible] between loud and
not quite as loud, but not quiet.
And so to move at an andante
tempo instead of [inaudible],
so not just moving fast or
slowly, but knowing the differences
in the speeds of walking.
So is it time for me to race walk
or do I need to walk leisurely.
This same ability to discern these
subtleties lets us listen intently
to others, and that keep ear
training differentiates leaders
who are really good listeners
from leaders who pay no attention
to those they're leading.
And really great listening skills
allow us to move our relationship
from surface to deep, because your
staff is no longer just following
you because you're the anointed
the leader, they're following you
because they felt heard by you.
And you're ability to listen
to others can transform them
because they have experienced your
in-depth ability to hear them,
and discern the subtleties.
In pulling people together,
leadership ability is highly
dependent upon being able
to pull people together,
and you can't really lead
unless you have followers.
And often the people that
you're pulling together,
not only come from
different perspectives,
but they may also not share
the same objectives as you.
So when do you give a people --
a group of people free
reign to express themselves
in a manner that's different
from you, and when do you reign
in everybody in the group
so that together you can
accomplish a single objective.
Composers ask those same questions
about the music they write.
They look for the times
and the pieces of music
where a single musician
might take a riff on her own,
and they look for other
times when all
of the performers have
come back together
for the sake of the composition.
And my musical training has helped
me understand when one voice needs
to be prominent and when to
bring that voice back down
and let another different voice
step out and make itself known.
Really effective leaders know when
to step forward, but they also know
when to hold back so
that others can lead.
They know when to dance with
exuberance and they know
when to be sensitive to
the stillness of the music.
And here's the key, neither approach
is right by itself all the time.
And an effective leader
understands this same context.
And because the arts are
a form of communication,
and we know that there are
different ways to express ourselves,
we can pay close attention
to what someone is saying,
even if they're using a different
vocabulary set, because, after all,
expressing ourselves through the
arts is just using a different
vocabulary set.
So I'm an only child, and
I was the first generation
to be born in the United States.
And I spoke English in my school
life and my parents spoke Mandarin
in my home life, and my
parents were not musicians,
nor were they arts aficionado,
but when my father died of cancer
when I was nine, those piano lessons
that I had been taking dutifully
turned out to be the only form
of expression I could use to
articulate my own grief as a child.
Because music gave me a broader
vocabulary than just the use
of linear everyday words,
and my music training
has helped me understand
that as a leader I can pay
attention to the ways others learn.
And at the heart of my musical
training was creativity,
so it's that same creativity that
allows us to see the patterns
and the connections
and the possibilities
when others don't see them.
To acquire meaning and value and
to build something from nothing,
to transcend those
situations which may appear
to have only one solution,
or possibly none,
the creativity gives us that ability
to see things in a different way
and it involves courage to step
out and do something in a way
that hasn't been done before.
Many of us in the arts are
here because we need to create
and we need to find ways
to innovate, and to be able
to use technologies, to deal with
change, and to take those resources
that are available to us
at any moment in time,
whether our resources are
abundant or whether they're scarce,
and use whatever we have to
create value and meaning.
And as leaders in creative fields,
we have this great opportunity
to provoke and create and
inspire, and we have an opportunity
to be lifelong learners
so that we won't be boxed
in by the same old tired arguments.
We have an opportunity to stand in
the midst of different perspectives
without shrinking back, and to
provide a working environment
that allows people to
generate new insights
and solve old problems in new ways.
To embolden creativity in
others and pay attention
to those fresh approaches
and ways of thinking.
So whether you have taken an
oath of office, as I have,
or you've started a company,
or you've introduced an idea
through a new approach, the arts
can bring together ideas and people
and perspectives, and from them
generate something beyond what we
could have envisioned on our own.
The arts an integral
component to my own leadership,
and not just because I'm
working in the arts field,
but because the arts have taught
me that how we do something is just
as important as what we
do, and that's the kind
of leadership that I'm aiming for.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Annette McLean: You know, while
you were speaking [inaudible]
from Mrs. Coolidge that one
can hear sometimes in our --
later in our exhibit, but it's
so resonant at this moment,
she said how wonderful it
would be to have in the cabinet
of secretary of fine arts.
This is a wonderful
opportunity for us
to congratulate you on
being that secretary.
>> Jane Chu: Thank you.
>> Annette McLean: Let's -- I
wanted to just take a quick --
before we go further, I wanted to
ask you a couple of quick questions,
and think about this for a moment.
How do we -- we talked about
how you define leadership,
how would you define the
success, that's one thing.
Do you have any comments for
people about how do you --
how does one develop
an authentic voice?
Tonight we'll hear Meredith
Monk, who has spent 50 years,
she's celebrating 50
years as an artist,
developing a very unique
authentic voice of her own.
Is there any comment you would
care to make on that question,
how to be an authentic self in
this process of becoming a leader.
That's a big question, I know.
And then, okay, while you're
resonating on that [laughter],
while you're thinking about that,
your Creativity Connects initiative
involves three different sectors,
business, private, giving
and corporate involvement.
Can you talk a little
bit about that?
>> Jane Chu: Well, we're launching
an initiative called Creativity
Connects, and it really is
because we're starting to look
across the nation and we're
seeing that the arts are not off
in a corner by themselves,
and they're not a frill,
but they infuse our lives every
day in so many different ways.
And sometimes they're the
beauty of arts themselves,
that's certainly the way
I came into the arts.
But we also see that they spike
creativity in other settings,
just as you had talked about --
both of you had talked about
before, Margaret and Astrid.
And so the Creativity Connects
initiative is an opportunity not
only to see the new ways
people are creating --
I was trained and I don't
-- maybe you were too,
but I was trained certainly that
when I wanted to either practice
or create on my own, to sequester
myself by myself in a room,
shut the door, don't get
tainted by these people
because you want the purity and the
authenticity of my own creation.
What I love about that
is I don't ever want
to give up my own authenticity.
But what I see is that I can do that
still and be in the room and learn
from others at the same time.
So the Creativity Connects
initiative is
about hooking the arts
to other areas.
Arts in -- connected to
business, arts connected
to other sectors that
want creativity.
Science, technology, you
can think of all kinds
of design, fashion, culinary.
So you'll start seeing, in
addition to what we currently find,
we'll add another program to spike
having arts be in other sectors.
Because other sectors are
starting to say, wait a minute,
we need the mindset of
an artist, because we --
they are already helping us
solve old problems in new ways.
So that's what the
initiative is about.
>> Annette McLean: Beautiful.
Back to success, any
thoughts on how you feel?
Because it's interesting, that's one
of the things that comes up a lot
when you read about these questions.
You know, you talked about
the work/life balance,
and there's a book now, Unfinished
Business by Anne-Marie Slaughter,
that's a brand new book,
that talks about this.
And it talks about the culture,
how we need to develop societal
mechanisms for balancing care giving
for the very old and the very young.
And whether there is a way that our
economic structure can support that,
that is a huge question.
But then, you know, faced with
those challenges, what is success
at a different point in
a women artists life,
a women administrator's life,
that's an important question.
Are there any other thoughts
on the concept of vision?
Because back to Mrs. Coolidge,
she's the inspiration for this,
have you had any thoughts
about when you knew you were
on the right track?
>> Margaret Lioi: I'm still
waiting to find out [laughter].
You know, it's interesting
thinking about vision and success.
I think what -- I think an important
thing, certainly an important thing
that we talk to our musician members
about is -- well, two things.
One is, certainly when I
was performing as a pianist,
there was a very clear
hierarchical structure.
So, you know, you would
play for ballet classes,
and then that was sort of
the low rung for pianists.
And then you would maybe play for
education programs in schools.
Then you might get
a gig with a singer
and you could have a
few weeks of the tour.
And I'm sure it was the
same for string players.
You would start doing things to get
credentials, but your goal was to go
up the ladder, and eventually
play, you know, at Carnegie Hall
or at the Kennedy Center.
And now success is not looked
at so much as a vertical line,
but much more as a
horizontal continuum.
So that people who play
engagements in schools,
education is so important,
and reaching young people is
so important, and they'll
do that maybe on a Thursday,
and then on Friday they're
playing in the concert hall.
And then on Saturday maybe
they decide they're playing
in a coffee shop, just
to reach people
that maybe didn't come
to the concert hall.
So musicians and administrators
as well I think are defining success
not as starting at the bottom
and going to the top, but what
makes you happy every day,
what makes you fulfilled every day.
And I think that's a big difference.
I think that technology and
expressing yourself publically
in a different kind
of way from certainly
when I was a younger person,
that was not acceptable.
There were -- there were only
a few people who were allowed
to have opinions and those people
were called critics [laughter].
And it isn't that way anymore.
So I think that success has
redefined itself really.
>> Annette McLean: Excellent.
Excellent.
You talked the other day
about having said something there
many kinds of artistic excellences
in many paths, and I --
that -- I remembered that.
This has been very interesting,
and we appreciate your thoughts
on the subject of leadership.
And I know that time is
running out so I want
to give the audience a chance
to ask some questions,
if you would like to.
We can open it up now
for just a few moment.
And we'll have the
microphones coming
around just here to facilitate this.
Okay.
>> I just wanted to thank --
everyone of your statements has
been just so incredibly meaningful.
I wanted to thank you all.
>> Margaret Lioi: Thank you.
>> And as I was listening to
each one of you, for example,
I went through school,
high school, college
and graduate school never
having a single women professor
in chemistry, in the
sciences, at all.
And so the parallels
between music and science
in our career times is identical.
And I applaud the Creativity
Connects, because I have to say
that most of the women scientists
I know also play an instrument,
and that's almost, you know,
an absolutely necessary
therapeutic counterbalance
to that solitary scientific
endeavor.
And so I wanted to ask, though,
for example, the media lab at MIT,
which I happen to know
very well, has --
you know, the media is [inaudible].
And so the arts and the sciences
have intertwined over the years,
not necessarily with women involved.
But I guess I'm interested
in your perspective
on the historical connection
and how that feeds into some
of the connectivities of -- and
perhaps if you have some experience
through your own musical education,
you mentioned at Mount Holyoake.
You're obviously dealing with
cellists who are majoring
in non-music, if you have
any comments on that as well.
>> Astrid Schween: Yeah, sure.
Well, that's one of the reasons I
enjoy my position at Mount Holyoake
so much -- it's just a little short.
There we go.
I do, as I said, work with so many
young women who are, you know,
likely future chairman's of major --
chairpersons of major corporations
or possibly even future presidents.
They're so bright and so
ambitious, and so creative.
And when they take the time to
come for a weekly cello lesson
or a chamber music session, I find
it's a great opportunity for us
to connect on this, especially
in the level of communication.
And how does one find
a voice and amplify
that through the texture
of the group.
Specifically you talked about
media and how that interacts
with -- intersects with music.
I think -- you know, I was
listing several classes
that Juilliard has offered,
and I have to say as somebody
who is stepping in, I
grew up at that school,
I was there from age seven to 20, so
I do feel like there's a little bit
of my blood on the walls
everywhere [laughter].
And I'm just so impressed now
coming back as a professor
to see the innovations that have
been made by President Polisi
and that he's addressing
this very issue.
That it's not enough to be
creative within your own Scarlatti
or [inaudible], but you
have to create a world
in which you can share this music.
And I think it's no accident that
classical music became so kind
of single minded for a while,
and was not successful
at being all inclusive.
So in a way, to have
our young people now
who are students use the media.
They're using social media, they're
doing all sorts of things to get --
to connect young people and
introduce them to classical music.
I think it's fantastic.
Exposure is everything.
It's the reason I play the cello,
and I imagine my colleagues here
had some similar experiences.
>> Hi. Very much appreciate
all that you all are doing.
Thank you very much for all
your dedication and commitment,
because I know it must have been
mammoth over all these years.
And I would just like to give a
little shout out to the composers.
>> Jane Chu: Yeah.
>> It seems like still that's a
section that is missing somehow.
I think of the commissions done
here by the Library of Congress,
and I wonder how many
have been won by women.
When they were talking about
their panel several months ago,
and picking people, I said,
do you do an anonymous
or do you do it some other way.
And they said, "No, we
know who we're seating."
And I just wonder if some blind
competitions might be better
to give women a chance that perhaps
unconsciously the men may not be as,
you know, accepting of.
But also in general, I can't think
of a single woman composer or note,
except in the popular field.
Meredith Monk, Carol --
what's her name, Carol King.
What's that?
Carol Sager [assumed
spelling], just in popular field.
I can't think -- I can't
think of a lot of --
>> Annette McLean: I think
of Jennifer Higdon [assumed
spelling] and [inaudible].
We're so pleased to say that --
>> Okay. Except [inaudible]
back in the 16th Century.
So I'm just hoping that all of you
all who are on panels are watching
out for the women who are
trying to get into that.
>> Annette McLean: I know
that Chamber Music America is
very, very much aware of this.
And, Margaret, we've
talked about this
about how gender blind listening
is important, and how you encourage
and seek out submissions for women.
And I can respond briefly on
behalf of the Library saying
that we are very excited
that we do have a number
of important substantive commissions
by female composers
in the last few years.
And we have a couple
more coming up this year.
If you look at our
brochure we are going
to have Gabriella Alana
Fronk [assumed spelling],
a new [inaudible] from
her [inaudible] Society.
But talk a little bit about -- yeah.
This is --
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
Or we can swap microphones
for a second.
>> Jane Chu: There you go.
Go ahead.
>> Margaret Lioi: Thank you.
Yes, actually Caroline Shaw just
won the Pulitzer Prize last year
for music.
I think it was last year.
And we have many, many --
actually Chamber Music America has
commissioned many women composers.
But you are absolutely right, they
are not as prominently programmed
as male composers on
chamber music programs.
I can only speak for chamber music.
But we do an awful lot of outreach.
When we are having our commissioning
program we contact the women
who have received commissions by
us, and ask them to, you know,
spread the word so that
more women will apply.
We've also -- we have a conference
every years, and we have had many,
many sessions on programming
compositions by women.
It's a an issue in the
classical musical field,
it is even a bigger
issue in the jazz field.
There are so few women
jazz musicians
and women jazz band leaders, and I
think this is just part of the field
that has to be brought
up to the same level
as the performing parts
of the field.
And to do it I think we
have to be very intentional.
There have to be some very
intentional steps taken
so that women have the opportunities
to compose and to be programmed.
So thank you for bringing that up.
>> Annette McLean: I
wanted to mention an article
that you might find interesting,
unfortunately we're --
I think we're almost out of time.
But the Guardian actually has a
lot of coverage of these kinds
of issues, the British newspaper.
And there was an article very
recently how the male domination
of classical music
may finally be coming
to an end, which is interesting.
But the article [inaudible] Jessica
Ducheon [assumed spelling] is the
women who wrote the article.
But what resonated in the back of
my mind about this was she talks
about the BBC recently,
Radio 3, did long series
of radio programs about
women composers.
And recently there was
a British music exam
on which almost no
composers were women,
or maybe only one was on the exam.
So this is a very timely issue.
But the great news is
that there is a lot
of very exciting things happening
and going on in this area.
So maybe just one more question,
then we need to go to the concert.
>> Good evening everyone, I'm
Kristy Wagner [assumed spelling],
Starlee Wagner is my pen name,
Starlee is my stage name.
I'd like to know what can be done
politically, men and women together,
to bring about the creation of
a Cabinet secretary of culture.
Hungary, since time in [inaudible]
has had a Minister of Culture.
France has had, Greece has had.
It's indefensible that we do not.
>> Jane Chu: Why are
you looking at me?
>> Margaret Lioi: Well - oh, here.
>> Annette McLean: I think just I'll
start out by just referring again
to the wonderful comment that
we were talking about earlier,
Mrs. Coolidge said, we have
a secretary of hygiene,
one of education, and
one of welfare,
but we do not have a
secretary of fine arts.
In fact, to have Jane
Chu is pretty amazing.
You're right that we
need to move forward,
and I'll let you speak to that.
>> Margaret Lioi: Well, I -- that's
actually a very controversial idea,
and there are many, many people
who are not in favor of it.
Not because -- because when you have
a cultural minister that also leads
to other kinds of issues
that we don't have to deal
with here in the United States.
I think that actually the --
having an agency the way
that we do is actually --
I think some of the European
countries look to the United States
to see how robust our philanthropy
is, which is based a great deal
on the presence of the
National Endowment,
and how it's grants leverage
money from the private sector.
That doesn't happen in the same way
when you have a Minister of Culture.
So I understand people's --
the impetus of we need somebody
there that's just for culture,
but there are other
consequences of having that system
that we don't have in this country.
And so I'm not so much
in favor of --
I'm in favor of Jane Chu [laughter].
I think she should do it.
>> Annette McLean: I think
that we are out of time.
We very much appreciate your coming.
We thank you, Chairman Chu,
Margaret Lioi, Astrid Schween.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.